Today i play the role of an expert in urban
planning, no, jokes aside, let's talk about
the mega-project to build the new administrative
capital of Egypt, announced by President Al-Sisi
at the international economic conference held
in Sharm el Sheik in March 2015.
There are many opinions about it: there are
those who consider it necessary to attract
foreign investors and realize a sort of Dubai
2.0 and those who instead consider it a waste
of money.
But let's go step by step.
The first attempts to transfer the government
center to the middle of the desert date back
to the second half of the 1970s.
Due to the demographic boom and the rapid
growth of the urban agglomeration, President
al-Sadat decided to build a new administrative
capital named after him in 1978, precisely
59 miles north-west of Cairo.
Actually, before him, a similar thing had
been done by president Nasser when, with the
enlargement of Heliopolis district, he founded
Nasr, which today is a soburb but according
to the initial projects it should have represented
the new Egyptian capital.
However Sadat's city maneged to grow for a
short period and also hosted some ministries,
including that of Housing, which remained
there for 8 months before returning to Cairo
after the assassination of al-Sadat himself.
The development of the city was totally abandoned
during the era of President Mubarak, as its
population barely reached one hundred fifty
thousand and most of the buildings that were
originally assigned to the ministries were
converted to house the newly established Menoufia
University.
Finally in 2014, the government of President
Al-Sisi dusted off plans for a new capital,
making it one of the priority objectives of
the development strategy named "Egypt 2030"
and which today raises several doubts about
its sustainability.
The strong interest in the project is witnessed
by the progress it has made in recent years
and many experts agree that two are the fundamental
reasons behind the revival of this ambitious
idea: the first is the need to legitimize
the presidential government in the eyes of
the population and the second is the intention
to move government institutions away from
the center of Cairo.
Theater of episodes such as the Arab Spring
unrest and the coup that led to the fall of
President Mohamed Morsi in 2013.
Let's talk about the project: after the failure
of the negotiations with Kuwait, Saudi Arabia
and United Arab Emirates and after the lack
of Chinese support for some differences on
the financial framework adopted, the Egyptian
government decided to make the first move
on its own by drawing on the national budget,
through a team of architects and designers
united under the name of Urban Development
Consortium +5.
In reality, Chinese companies have never completely
disappeared, but their investments (for a
declared amount of 1.2 billion dollars) are
nothing more than limited loans: these funds,
in fact, can only be spent on Chinese-sourced
equipment, including material for a new metro
system that should connect the new capital
to Cairo and for what will be the tallest
tower in Africa, partially assigned to the
China State Construction Engineering Corporation.
While the company in charge of construction
and management of the entire city is Administrative
Capital for Urban Development (ACUD), whose
majority share is in the hands of the Ministry
of Housing (51%) and the remaining 49% in
the hands of the Armed Forces.
Rising from the sands 27 miles east of Cairo
towards the Suez Canal, the New Capital is
the last and largest desert city promoted
by the rejiim.
But enterprises of this magnitude aren t unusual
in Egypt, and past regimes have always considered
them the panacea for all ills.
As for example the Great Aswan Dam was seen
as the final solution to the problem of the
distribution of the waters of the Nile, so
in our case the new capital claims to solve
the problems of unemployment, transportation
and overpopulation.
The promises are many: to lighten the load
on the real estate market of Greater Cairo,
to accommodate the city's growing population,
to reduce pollution and traffic congestion.
So the government has presented the New Capital
as a pole of attraction for international
investment and a center of economic growth.
Thanks to the industrial drawings, we can
get an idea of the layout of the future city:
an area covering over two hundred seventy
square miles (275), 68 of which have been
developed in the first phase until 2018, intended
to accommodate over 6 million Egyptians (6.5).
It is divided into several sectors: that of
the Wedian residential neighborhoods, divided
into high, medium and low density zones (which
will rifl ct the future costs of the housing
units there) with educational services and
social and health infrastructure; the business
district, consisting of offices, an industrial
area and a solar farm (a solar park that is
expected to cover 70% of the city's energy
needs); a complex of parks with a serpentine
shape that intends to imitate the course of
the Nile River for an extension of 9.6 square
miles; a large airport; then we have the government
district, which will host ministries and public
offices and finally the presidential palace.
For the way it is structured it looks like
an urbanized part of the agglomeration of
Cairo (the so-called greater network, which
includes several satellite cities) and this
is derived from the fact that the megaproject
will not have its own governorate, but will
fall instead under the administrative responsibility
of the governorate of Cairo.
All this for the modest sum of between 45
and 58 billion dollars.
But is everyone in agreement on achieving
such a feat?
Obviously not, there are different lines of
thought but let's talk about how the government
justifies such an expenditure of human and
economic resources.
Supporters see in such an ambitious project
the birth of a Dubai of the Mediterranean,
perfect for attracting national and foreign
investments and tourism.
Taking Dubai as a point of reference is not
wrong, especially if we consider the image
that the Emirates metropolis has managed to
offer in the last 40 years, with the tallest
skyscraper in the world, enormous artificial
islands and the largest airport in the Middle
East.
And what are the unofficial reasons?
Al-Sisi wants to use the new capital to strengthen
his position, winning over the private business
sector and gaining back the popular support
that had sustained him during the bloody crackdown
on the Muslem Brotherhood movement.
In fact, recent events such as the devaluation
of the national currency (the pound), the
repression of critical voices, the increase
in fuel prices and the border clashes with
Sudan, have left their scars on the legitimacy
of the president and his administration.
Instead, the 2011 revolution that led to Mubarak's
downfall is important in understanding why
the move of government institutions is so
imminent; it was originally scheduled for
2019 but postponed due to the pandemic.
The revolution was primarily urban and gained
momentum due to the popular mass concentrated
in Cairo where networks and media allowed
civilians to organize and mobilize quickly.
This resulted in a huge wave of people emerging
from the center, nearby areas, historic parts
and even the wealthiest neighborhoods to gather
in symbolic places such as Tahrir Square,
the cradle of the Arab League's HQ, the center
of Egyptian bureaucracy Mogamma, the Nasser-era
Nile Hilton Hotel and finally the headquarters
building of Mubarak's National Democratic
Party.
Same procedure was followed during the coup
that deposed President Morsi in 2013.
Therefore, the current regime is well aware
of the iconic power of the Square and this
explains the aspiration of the authorities
to abandon the old and overpopulated Cairo
and move to their happy oasis in the middle
of the desert, far from the people they have
to govern and from their unpredictable movements.
If the displacement of the institutions is
now confirmed, can we say the same about entire
families of ordinary citizens?
Who will be able to live in the new capital
once completed?
The prices of housing units are prohibitive.
Think that a two-bedroom apartment costs about
fifty thousand dollars, a huge sum that is
out of reach for many in a country where the
GDP per capita is about three thousand dollars.
The big risk then, unless the government takes
appropriate action, is that the new capital
will act as a cage for the rich and do little
to meet the needs of poor and disadvantaged
residents.
This is why the New Administrative Capital
is already seen by many as a colossal waste
of resources.
Critics say that it would have been better
to spend that money on improving living conditions
in the poor parts of the old capital or even
better to reduce regional disparities across
Egypt by providing services, job opportunities
and projects to improve the overall quality
of life.
In response to these criticisms, the authorities
have stated that the city will also include
social housing, but didn t provide details
on when it will be built and made available
to those in need.
All of this brings to mind the regime of Hosni
Mubarak and his downfall.
The last decade of his government was supported
by the rise of wealthy capitalist lobbies
that helped the economy grow, but prevented
the benefits of this growth from reaching
the poorest sectors of society.
And indeed, one of the most prominent slogans
in the January 2011 protests that overthrew
the Mubarak regime was "social justice."
Who knows if history will repeat itself, one
thing is certain, Al-Sisi's new fortress will
make the hypothetical uprising just a little
more difficult to accomplish.
Well, we are done for today, I hope i gave
you a clear idea of what will happen soon
in this part of North Africa, we will hear
about it again in the near future.
See you in the next video.
Bye